yeah so we watched that Tick Tock of  that dude interviewing kids on the BYU  campus about what their favorite party  drink was two specific mentions were  eggnog and lemonade and something I  didn't think about is and Kool-Aid Man  come on man Kool-Aid so they hit me  Afters when you drink all those things  you're still thirsty yeah yeah totally  so if all those people are drinking  those things at a party just thirsty as  a [ __ ] the whole time just Slammy eggnog  like I wish I had water  well we have more eggnog  you want someone oh yeah I guess I'll  have another glass maybe that'll maybe  that'll quench my thirst chasing eggnog  with lemonade  curdling in your stomach you're just  making gouda cheese in there man  you know that brick of mozzarella you  can get in the store yeah but you like  cut open like an egg yeah yeah that's  what comes out of your ass when you live  on the BYU campus